I asked young voters across the country
what words come to mind when you think
of the Republican Party and it was
things like close-minded racists
intolerant old-fashioned stuck in the
nineteen fifties I am nickel SP with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Kristen Soltis Anderson she's the author
of the new book the selfie vote where
Millennials are leading America and how
Republicans can keep up Kristen thanks
for having me all right talk about what
are the main insights that we should
know about Millennials you know where
are they socially economically
politically so the world is changing
very quickly and our politics have
really failed to keep up it's kind of
hard to make a generalization about such
a large group of people but in general
the trends were seeing our trends away
from living in rural areas towards more
densely populated areas but they are
much more ethnically and racially doing
for much more ethnically and racially
diverse and their political impact has
only just begun beginning to be felt so
the baby boomers right now the
proportion of them that vote is pretty
high but frankly they're go there's
going to be fewer and fewer of them as
we move along the Millennials haven't
even begun to fully exercise their their
political weight because some of them
aren't even old enough to vote yet what
what ethnic groups are making up the
Millennials and then how do F Nick
groups change because you know it's
different to be italian-american in 1900
mm exactly so one we're seeing a huge
expansion of the Hispanic population and
what a lot of folks don't realize is
this is not as a result of immigration
it's folks that are born here
nowadays in a state like New Mexico and
most children who are born are Hispanic
and so the trend lines demographically
are sort of you there's they are very
clear if you took a look at the exit
polls in the 2012 election Mitt Romney
actually won young white voters mm-hmm
by seven points but this is such a
diverse generation that he winds up
losing the youth vote overall by 23
points because he did so badly with
non-white young voters so in the
diversity of this generation it's
something like less than less than 60%
are white and and that numbers only
growing as the younger Millennials come
of age you know we say the greatest
generation and the ones before the
Boomers came out into post war America
they were
had a huge booming economy what are the
Millennials face millenials are facing a
really tough economy and they're facing
difficulty getting jobs in the fields
that they want they're facing trouble
getting jobs that offer some kind of
career path or growth they're also
struggling to be able to save up enough
to make some of the big purchases the
previous generation viewed as signs of
adulthood so things like buy exactly you
know homeownership is kind of at its
lowest since the government really began
collecting data on this and I think the
early 80s for the younger generation
it's not that they don't want to buy
homes I mean on a variety of fronts this
is kind of a commitment-phobic
generation and buying a home is a pretty
big commitment you know as they were
coming of age their parents homes were
being foreclosed on they can see the
foreclosure signs around the block they
saw their parents 401ks evaporate so
things like investing in the stock
market putting your money into a house
they're very they don't think that those
things that we might have previously
thought of as safe financial decisions
they're not for you too safe they want
to save money in a mattress very small
see conservative and are they are they
more entrepreneurial than previous
generations you hear that a lot and
every hipster is selling rather
moustache wax or something so in spirit
yes in practice not as much in part
because of that sort of small C fiscal
conservatism and and risk aversion they
want to be able to do this they want to
be able to start businesses they want to
be their own boss they don't want to be
told what to do and go into some big
corporate structure but the idea of
starting your own business is also
pretty risky and you need to have
somebody save it up and if you're paying
off student loans sometimes that can be
too risky a proposition do Millennials
tend to see work as expressive of their
values and identity in a way that is
distinct from previous generation very
much so I think a phrase I've heard is
that mission driven I mean that where
you work is kind of an expression of who
you are not just something that you do
to work to get a paycheck to pay the
bills so that you can be who you are
off-hours and that kind of blurring of
lines between work and life is a big
thing I think it has to do one with you
can't get away from work when you leave
work you've got your phone with you all
the time
but they also want to do something in
their job that they feel is meaningful
they don't just want to push papers all
day they want to feel like they're
making the world a better
place I think the opportunity there for
folks who are free-market leaning is I
think there's a huge opportunity to talk
about how the market can solve problems
and the stuff you do for your work can
solve big problems in society rather
than a government program how do you
reach Millennials because they're also I
mean they look different they have you
know different values they have
different net worth you know what are
what are their media habits or you know
where do they get their messages where
do they get their news where do they
have their conversation I think a lot of
politicians think they could just get on
Facebook and Twitter and they've checked
the box
well actually Facebook is now more of an
older person's game it's it's got more
parents than non parents Twitter is more
an activist space rather than a youth
space it's a lot of visual storytelling
apps and a lot of mobile video is where
young folks are at these days snapchat
Instagram that's where I think
politicians I'm hopeful that they will
begin trying to use this to reach people
and use it effectively Rand Paul was one
of the first to sign up for snapchat but
also you can't just use these tools you
know sitting there in your suit and tie
and your congressional office like I'm
gonna snapchat you have to actually do
it to tell an interesting story and what
do you have do you have an example of
that where a politician has used new
media or social media to tell a good
story in a different way so there there
aren't a ton of good examples I think
one of the ones that I go back to a lot
is in the 2012 campaign the contrast
between how Barack Obama and Mitt Romney
used something like Facebook so for Mitt
Romney's Facebook page it was a lot of
click here to donate here's information
about our latest rally here's the latest
news article about this outrageous thing
that Obama has done the obama face book
page on the other hand was a mix of that
and pictures of him with the dog
pictures of you know him and his wife
telling that personal story when you go
on facebook it's a mix of news links and
personally and then you mentioned in the
book that romney oddly after the
election now his facebook feed and he's
also on medium he's kind of telling
personal stories about right and I think
that suddenly gives him this credibility
where people who previously thought of
him as this evil supervillain now can
see hey actually he's not such a bad guy
you you were saying you can't just put
on a suit and then like do an ad that
you
have done for you know the ABC News or
like Meet the Press and just broadcast
it on snapchat you really have to be
kind of in treating people and having
more of a dialogue in a conversation
things have been leveled the mighty are
not as mighty and the weak are not as
weak exactly that there's the sense that
our politicians live in a bubble they
live lives totally separate from ours
and they they just live in this
alternate reality and they don't get
what people like me are going through
and to the extent that that's in many
ways very true the social media
platforms can allow them very briefly to
kind of drop that veil and and show hey
actually you know just like you I you
know I I have tastes in pop culture and
I am a normal human being I am NOT just
a caricature I think that's a real
opportunity there's a string of ask ask
me anything son reddit that are
hilarious when celebrities are
politicians go on and then the questions
immediately get nasty and it's a kind of
test to see if they can roll with that
or if they just kind of yeah and I think
the ability to laugh at yourself is a
big part of thriving in online
communication too I mean I mentioned in
the book President Obama going on
between two ferns being able to laugh at
himself a little bit about the
disastrous rollout of the Affordable
Care Act exchanges just yesterday I
think there was a video of Lindsey
Graham sort of making fun of himself
about how Donald Trump gave out his cell
phone number like very quickly turned
around a funny video online you know the
ability to kind of laugh at yourself I
think is a big part of it you know that
is fascinating generationally because
you can see a lot of conservatives in
particular really huff and puff about
how could Obama talk to what's her name
a flow cell or
yeah as well as you know as well as
between two ferns to be singing Al Green
songs or even Amazing Grace and in a lot
of ways that you know goes into a
another section about the book is that
our Republicans so out of it that they
seem to be doing everything possible to
ally innate themselves from anybody
under 50 it's it's definitely been a
challenging number of years I did focus
groups in 2013 that I talked about a lot
in the book where I asked young voters
across the country what words come to
mind when you think of the Republican
Party
it was things like close-minded racist
intolerant old-fashioned stuck in the
1950s and Republicans I I don't know
have done enough recently to try to
combat that image I mean every so often
you'll have one or two who try to do
things well with the overall image still
needs a lot of work yeah and I mean in
one of your chapters you talk about you
know showing up and reaching out and
really I mean Rand Paul stands out as
somebody who's doing that he's actually
mixing it up with younger younger voters
he's also calling for more kind of
inclusion of minorities is anybody else
doing that and even his efforts are kind
of half-assed to be quite honest yeah I
mean a lot of times when Republicans try
to figure out how am I going to reach
young voters well intentioned but
misguided efforts are focused on
pretending to be cool which always comes
across as phony and is not the way this
was like wearing mom jeans as opposed to
doing criminal justice reform so but if
you take a look at somebody like a Ron
Paul I mean he actually got he won the
Republican primaries among young voters
in certain key early states and he's not
the hippest coolest guy on the debate
stage by any stretch of the imagination
but that's not necessarily what people
are looking for they're looking for
someone who seems authentic and I think
that's something that a lot of
Republicans miss when trying to tackle
this how much a couple things says you
you've worked with the college national
College Republicans on focus groups in a
poll a couple years ago that was great
and you know interestingly all there
were a ton of negative things said about
the Republicans as a kind of general
brand and yet I remember in that poll
there it was also when they were asked
who are like interesting Republicans
there was a long list many of whom are
running for president now and I'm the
Democratic side besides Hillary Clinton
who you know he's ancient you know in
political terms there was nobody right
what did so what explains that I mean
the Republicans are younger but they're
less hip personally I think the average
age not only of Republicans running for
president but of Republicans in Congress
I think is actually significantly lower
than the Democrats began ages is sort of
nothing but a number right if you're you
can be 22 but in the like the navy
blazer with the gold buttons and the bow
tie and have a very I'm 60 years old
mentality so and I worry that
Republicans need to demonstrate that
they
they not just through image not just
through what you dress or what you like
but that you actually get that not
everybody's ultimate dream in life is to
have the mom and the dad and the white
picket fence and the 2.5 kids and the
dog and you work at the same company
real hard for 30 years and you know
people have very different visions for
how they want to live their lives I
think Republicans need to talk about not
how we want to empower a particular type
of way of living but how we want to help
people live the way of life that makes
them happy it can the Republicans
actually stay true to their kind of
conservative sensibilities and be like
oh no you know what actually gay
marriage is fine the government should
treat everybody equally I mean it just
seems to me you're asking the
Republicans to fundamentally change
everything that they stand for I'm try
trying a selfie vote to actually find
areas more so I think on the the fiscal
and economic issues than perhaps on the
social issues but to find areas where
they don't have to change what they
believe they just have to explain why
their principles apply to 21st century
problems and the 21st century way of
life I I think you know sort of
transparently changing your views on
things and suddenly like Hillary Clinton
saying that you've always been this
advocate for LGBT rights but really as
of five minutes ago you weren't
I think that's transparent I think young
voters would see through that if all of
a sudden every Republican woke up
tomorrow and said you know what I've
changed my mind on gay marriage I think
what you did see after the Supreme Court
ruling though was this really broad
spectrum of responses from Republican
candidates he saw some that said let's
get her to the Supreme Court or let's
not enforce this but you had others that
said look I believe marriage is between
a man and a woman the Supreme Court has
said what they said let's all be
tolerant and love one another and
protect religious freedom and move on
from here and I thought that was sort of
a best-case scenario you know as much as
I'm a supporter of marriage equality I
get where these folks are at all right
well we will leave it there we've been
talking with Kristen Soltis Anderson and
the book is the selfie vote where
Millennials are leading America and how
Republicans can keep up Kristen thank
you thanks for having me for reason TV
I'm Nicolas ting